donc tout d'abord
nous a quittés exane est à l'âge de plus
de 100 ans
quand même elle a passé ces derniers
jours chez ma tante en ville au vietnam
en compagnie de ses enfants et de ses
petits-enfants donc les liens que
j'entretenais avec grand moment et puis
dernier privilégie qui existe encore
aujourd'hui même après son départ il est
d'ordre spirituel aujourd'hui mais mais
il existe encore et grand maman fait
encore partie de mon quotidien
mais pour répond plus spécifiquement à
la question c'est évident qu'ils soient
lien de filiation citoyens à mes
origines c'est un lien à ma petite
histoire familiale
cette année à ma culture et tout c'est
tous ces liens je considère qu'il
participe à la construction de mon
identité
alors ils sont sont très importants
star
c'est un rappel qu'elle me faisait à
chaque fois que je retourne au vietnam
me rappelant mon histoire lorsqu'elle
dit tu dois honorer ses ancêtres
ça voulait dire du doigt doit respecter
ton histoire tu dois te rappeler d'où tu
viens qui doit garder cette histoire en
toi notre histoire son histoire mon
histoire celle de mes parents
et c'est ce lien vers le passé qui
aujourd'hui je réalise il est très
important
d'ailleurs dans notre dans notre culture
asiatique vietnamiens le vietnam n'a pas
de temps de verbe
donc on marque l'espace temps dans une
phrase par il ya aujourd'hui demain par
un marqueur par un mood simplement
conjugue pas nouvelle et saas en dit
beaucoup sur la philosophie sur notre
façon de concevoir la vie qu'ont souvent
le temps est notre rapport aux à ses
différents espaces temporels le parti le
présent et le futur et trouve ça très
intéressant parce que parce que parce
que parce que le saas que ça d'ici que
le passé appartient au présent et le
futur à partir en prison ici donc on
fait pas de distinction on s'est parfois
le parti on ne laisse pas de côté au
look ippon les quatre membres ne jette
pas les aînés font partie du présent les
ennemis font partie notre jeunesse la
jeunesse d'été est incluse dans dans la
vieille chose que je trouve très
intéressant que que j'essaie d'appliquer
au quotidien et est donc voilà c'est je
pense que c'est ce qu'elle croit
vraiment essayé de m'appeler et
aujourd'hui ce sont que moi je vis dans
une vie très loin de cette culture est
de 7 et de ces philosophies
si tous ces souvenirs leurs deux grands
moments toutes ses phrases là et même
mon film qui est devenu une espèce de
cap et est très important aujourd'hui
dans ma vie tout ça est très important
parce que ça me rappelle que je suis
cette année
croyez le ou non aux jeux ça m'arrive de
louviers est ce que québec puisse bien
dans cette culture occidentale sur
québécoise
alors j'ai tendance à l'oublier alors
voilà les grands parents sont là pour ça
ou si vous appelez un peu notre passé et
notre histoire
j'ai un projet documentaire de fiction
et justement ça poursuit cette ça
poursuit ses 7 4 les originaux ce point
qu'un de mes origines mais saborde ses
préoccupations donc rapport à mon
histoire mes origines et ma fiction à la
banque justement cette c'est l'histoire
d'un garçon qui tacle et a vu sa vie de
jeune adulte et a quitté le nid familial
au moment où sa grand tante qui s'est
occupé d'elle qui s'est occupé lui
pardon toute sa vie thomas l'a donc il
se retrouve entre autres doit choisir
entre entre son épanouissement personnel
et les ses devoirs de devoirs familiaux
celui de s'occuper de sa famille et
j'aborde tous ces thèmes parce que ça
fait vraiment partie de ces des valeurs
qui s'opposent mais qui qui habite qui
m'habite
donc je me retrouve souvent à imposer
cette question pas me poser cette
question mais à constater que parfois je
suis profondément vietnam n'est donc pas
très québécois et ça crée une espèce de
friction qui est très intéressant pour
moi et qui me permet de qu'il devient tu
deviens le moteur de mes créations pour
aborder ce thème là cette opposition
entre individualités et collectivités
donc voilà